Chris Mannix Sports Illustrated joining
us on the program as we talk about what
is going on in China the fallout from
that what happened today in China Chris
well I mean I think the the most recent
developments are that you know Adam
silver took a stronger position and
because of that we have seen you know
even further fallout from China with you
know the decision to not show the games
on CCTV the images I'm seeing and you're
seeing of banners coming down at the
arena's questions about whether the game
between the nets and the Lakers are
going to take place or are there I mean
it's it's continuing to evolved in but I
think the strongest thing that happened
was that the NBA cleaned up its mistake
that initial statement was nothing more
than a word salad that didn't mean a
whole lack of a lot Adam Silver came out
and yesterday and clarified all this and
and and I think they've done a lot
better in the last 24 hours
what is China want I mean I think in an
ideal world they like Daryl Morey fired
and the NBA to disavow his comments but
I mean that clearly isn't gonna happen I
mean it just isn't I understand that
Daryl put the NBA in a bit of a
compromised situation because of how
much money is at stake but I mean think
about how bad the NBA was low status if
they even sanctioned them at all I find
them wait did you say a bit of a
compromising situation I'm being
diplomatic here I guess to say the least
but yeah I mean look he's costing them
some money I mean I think the only
question now then is how much money did
that tweet ultimately cost the NBA every
night I think it's fair to wonder can
China really kick the NBA out of its
country mean an authoritarian government
like that can do a lot but the
toothpaste kind of out a tube here like
there are a lot of people in China that
watch NBA basketball and that you know
you know worship these guys as athletes
as top players you can't just say well
we're going to show more Chinese
Basketball Association games
instinct and the players in the games
are only good because they've got like
washed-up NBA players
Chris don't don't get on China's bad
sign here how about you say they're
their quality of basketball is less than
the NBA I mean you've really known me to
kind of take that position just I'm
worried about you
animals it's bad it's bad basketball
okay okay and you can you can simply
have on any xcb a player that's now back
in the u.s. they will tell you it's bad
basketball how do you think this is
being told to China like the do you
think that the citizens even know about
it
well it's I'm sure they know about it I
mean I spent some time early in the week
talking to Ben Rhodes who's a former
national security adviser for Barack
Obama and and he said that you know
through state-run media you know China
is spending this and whatever way they
want to spin it I would say it's kind of
goofy to suggest that a tweet from Daryl
Morey has had an impact on the Chinese
people since Twitter as Larson blocked
in China so how would they even be able
to see what Daryl Morey said it's also I
think a little ridiculous as Joseph Tsai
the owner of the net suggests that you
know although the billions of people in
China whatever number it is are United
you know and how they feel about what's
going on Hong Kong I don't think that's
true either so I think it's being spun
in in a way by the by China but I'm not
so sure exactly what every citizen there
feels how does this get worse I guess it
could get worse if sometime in the next
24 hours LeBron James something strong
on the issue
it certainly could get worse if Donald
Trump weighs in on the issue we're
seeing a lot of right-wing media you
know criticize NBA players and coaches
for not speaking up on all this I guess
that could go to another level but Dan I
don't know about you but I don't have a
huge problem with you know players and
coaches not weighing in on all this it's
you know just because you comment on
California versus the n-c-double-a
or have a problem with some of the
policies of positions of Donald Trump
fakes I don't think that requires or
compels you to weigh in on a decades-old
international incident I just don't
think it does and I would challenge
people criticizing those players to ask
themselves if a week ago they had a
position in all this if a week ago they
could have fully explained exactly what
was going on between Hong Kong and China
if you couldn't why should a 25 year old
basketball player or even a fortune 50
something your own coach be expected to
have a strong position on all this so I
guess that's a long way of saying that
if the the right-wing media attacks you
know pick up and all of a sudden bigger
politicians get involved this could
continue to spiral do you think the
players are told not to talk or not
being made available or if you want to
talk I saw James Harden had some
comments but I don't know if the Nets
and Lakers are being made available to
the media from what I just from the
reporters of China it sounds like the
availability was canceled for today at
some point that this game goes forward
they're gonna have to speak and even if
it's not now they'll speak when they get
back in to the United States so I think
they'll have to say something on this
topic and I don't believe the NBA is
telling them anything I don't think they
can do that I do think there are
conversations that have or will take
place between players and their sneaker
companies I think that's for sure
I think sticker companies are going to
have some advice on on how to handle
this given the business that they do in
China but players I think from an NBA
perspective are free to say whatever
they want how would Commissioner Stern
handle this or have handled this any
different ah it's a good question I was
reading excerpts from my my former
colleague Jack McCallum had a piece you
know on that he quoted on David Stern
where it's read it but he basically you
know articulated that Stern had a lot of
you know he grappled with with how to
deal with China so I'm not sure he would
handle it all that differently now
certainly I don't think David Stern took
as much of a progressive stance
as Adam silver ha I don't know the David
Stern would handle some of the stuff
that Gregg Popovich has said and Steve
Curtis said and players assume the same
way that Adam Silver has so maybe he
would have encouraged encourage them to
be to be more diplomatic or to be
quieter on the subject but I still don't
know if there's anything the NBA can do
what it's fern or silver to muzzle this
type of stuff you think this game is
played tomorrow well they have two games
the the nets and the Lakers do you think
they're played in in China you're just
guessing I would say no it just well you
know look looking at some of the visuals
of these banners being taken down and
how this doesn't seem to be escalating
any time seer in fact is only escalating
at that point now I don't know what
conversations that Silver's have it
today with officials in China I know
he's trying to talk to people over there
and and and sort of just try to settle
this in a a common reasonable manner but
at this point you know that they I mean
then they cancel like things that
benefit the school systems things that
benefit the Special Olympics I don't
know I don't see how given the precedent
of the last you know 24 hours how it's
anyone could pick it's likely they'd go
forward with these games
Chris great stuff we appreciate your
time as always thanks for joining us
again that's Chris Mannix works for
Sports Illustrated covering boxing and
of course the NBA works for ozone as
well for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]